[Music]
hello and welcome back to Google Goggles
2017 come in to you live from San
Francisco I'm Timothy Jordan a developer
advocate and host of the dev show and
I'm Dre Alfonzo a program manager on
Google for education and one of the
hosts of the G Suites show and we're
back for another full day we're excited
to kick it off with you and give you a
peek at what's going on here in San
Francisco today we can expect to learn
more about Google cloud products
including new launches for GCP and G
suite along with that our top product
and engineering leaders will share
roadmaps and future product direction
we'll also check out some cool demos and
hear from customers about how Google
cloud is helping them compete and
succeed yesterday over 10,000 people
attended Google cloud next to
collaborate and learn we heard from some
group we heard some great announcements
in the keynote such as eBay and HSBC now
running on Google cloud platform the
general availability of ASAP Hana on
Google cloud platform and a bunch of
machine learning updates including the
Google cloud video intelligence API
cloud machine learning engine now in
general availability cloud vision API
1.1 in beta and kaggle joining Google
cloud yeah why do we go to a clip with a
few more highlights from day one
[Music]
this is just an incredibly exciting
event everybody at Google cloud is so
incredibly proud of the customers that
we have here today ninety percent of our
users are active on Google Drive and in
February alone we had more than 57,000
hours of video hangouts I'm more excited
by the investments you guys are making
in talent and I'm looking forward to the
work we're gonna do on exploring some
some really interesting problems where
we think that the machines can help us
understand some things perhaps that the
humans Minds at the moment understand
Google let me talk to even sure here's
even hi I'm Eva
I'm the world's price guide this is why
the next step for AI must be
democratization we at Google cloud are
making the tools available but it's up
to you to put them to use our customers
and partners will see many ways to
leverage all of Google feed Google Maps
Android YouTube our devices ecosystem
and we'll deliver it for the most
efficient high performing and secure for
computing resources just get the cloud
now there's no time to waste any more
you know we also had a chance to chat
with some attendees about their
experience here at next let's take a
look at what they had to say let's do it
alright I know we're supposed to be
doing attendee interviews but I just
couldn't pass up this opportunity
Here I am with great Wilson head of
developer relations for cloud Greg
welcome to the show
Thanks glad to be here I watch you show
all the time so it's cool to be on it
finally there's like a million here but
we spotted you okay so what we're doing
right now is trying to give everybody an
idea out there what it feels like to be
at cloud next right now can you you've
been walking around the showcase how
does it feel really good there's a lot
of lot of energy a lot of people looking
for new things to learn I mean cloud is
hot right now you know no matter who
you're using everyone's looking to get
out of managing their own infrastructure
and trying to find a provider that can
you know offer them the services that do
it for them
so that's what we're all about in cloud
we you know we launched machine learning
engine this morning to GA and the video
intelligence API so I already talking to
a lot of developers here that already
having some really interesting ideas on
how to use that in real applications and
that's why I'm here is just to learn
what how do people see this stuff what
are they thinking about using it for and
it's fascinating you know it's great to
be a Googler and then learn about Google
products through the eyes of someone
else right so it's fantastic so hey
everyone i'm with diana from search ago
so Diana talk to us a little bit more
about what you do at surgical and
exactly who is certified well
certificates a cloud partner basin Ola
Tom region we are like the biggest
partner and we offer D suite and D cloud
in Latin region so as a partner we had
our partner at summit yesterday so talk
to us about what that experience was
like well it's very very interesting to
have this conversation with all the VPS
at Google and understanding what are the
important things they want us to know
just to share with our clients or with
our prospects so it's very very
interesting this meeting
a great day to kick off the first day
yeah and today was our keynote sessions
we had some our speaker sessions as well
and what were some of the cool things
that stood out to you in those and those
two things actually it's the first thing
that there is the partners coming and
also acquired some so mix them all
together it's very interesting for us
because we can understand now like more
customer success stories things like
that that was one of the most
interesting things in the morning for me
a lot of attendees are really excited
about all the innovative stuff happening
with Google cloud but you know some of
them aren't sure how they can best keep
up you know that's a good point I'm not
sure if you know this but last week
Google announced a collaboration with
Coursera an online learning platform and
I sat down with Louise who had an
important role in making all that happen
hey everyone I'm here with Louise Brinn
head of training delivery at Google
cloud last week Google cloud announced a
new collaboration with Coursera an
online learning platform which sounds
pretty exciting
so can we before we get started can you
tell us more about how this addresses
some of the technical skills gap around
the cloud yeah definitely I mean we're
all seeing hugely excited to have this
collaboration with Coursera and one of
the things that we you know have heard
consistently from our customers from
partners from developers as well as what
recent research has also shown is that
one of the biggest challenges and for
organizations and individuals to move
and take advantage of cloud products in
general is skills gaps it has been cited
as the number one concern that companies
have and moving to the cloud and we
believe that our investment in training
and more specifically this collaboration
with Coursera will enable us to help
close this skills gap by working with
Coursera what it enables us to do is
provide training in an on-demand format
that can be consumed by anyone anywhere
in the world and in a timeframe that
works for them right so with the
training can you talk a little bit more
about what the what the training looks
like and what type of courses are
available yeah so we're really excited
again with
with Coursera because it's timed with
also the launch of some new training
that we have around big data and machine
learning huge amount of interest
obviously in in the whole area of
machine learning and so we have that
which is just in general and a new
course we're adding that to to Coursera
from the get-go and we also have our
systems operations course up there and a
specialization Aransas ops and which is
the course that maps to the
infrastructure kind of focus of the
Google cloud platform products and and
there is many more courses to come these
I'm going to watch this space over the
coming months for the other courses
coming down the line so addition we are
talking about with with Coursera and now
with our acquisition of quick labs how
do those how do those to tie in together
yeah I mean I think that they tie in
really well I mean first is obviously
they show the commitment and focus that
Google cloud is giving to training and
we were taking this very very seriously
in terms of doing whatever we can to
help close the skills gap and enable
people so that they can take advantage
of the opportunities that working with
Google cloud products can can bring and
I think also what it really shows is our
and learner first approach and what is
wonderful about the quick labs platform
is that it provides learners with real
live environments on which they can
practice whatever it is that they have
learned from the courseware from the
materials mm-hmm and they can go and
implement that in a in a practice
environment which is what is what the
labs offer and combining that with the
Coursera just means that you have a
really high quality training product
that can be consumed anywhere by anyone
so yeah application exactly
so we're from the courses and training
that we talked about where can we go to
learn more yes and you might be
surprised to hear there is a website and
it's on it's a Google cloud site yeah so
if you go to that site it will provide
all the information you need and what
courses we have available what
certifications are on offer
and the partnerships and where you can
actually go and find the the training
whether that it is instructor-led
training or the on-demand training that
we were doing together with Coursera got
it now there any special offerings or
discounts with the new training yeah I
mean together with us making this
announcement we are super excited to
offer everyone who's attending next and
the next extended event a venture M for
some Coursera training the voucher is
valid for the Google Cloud fundamentals
course normally valued at $59 anyone
with this voucher can consume that
training for free so we're really really
delighted to be able to announce that
together at Coursera awesome so a lot of
great trainings courses out there to
learn all about the cloud so thanks
Louise for joining us we're gonna kick
it back to the showcase in San Francisco
to see what's happening at cloud next
thank you thanks you know there's lots
to learn see and do here so we wanted to
make sure everyone got a glimpse into
what next is about in addition to the
keynotes and sessions that's right
yesterday we took a tour of the cloud
showcase where you can get really
hands-on with everything happening here
at next and of course we brought some
cameras along the way and this is what
we saw
[Music]
okay we're now at the Hoover Nettie's
Wacka pod booth with Mandy Mandy how are
you I'm pretty good fine Kate how's the
game it's going fantastic so just a
moment ago Draya and I were playing
whack a pod and it was a lot of fun but
you could tell could you tell us what we
were doing while we were whacking those
pods yeah we're working pods so these
pods are parts of components of an
application that are running within
kubernetes we have the setup is a little
bit kind of geared towards the
experience specifically but the idea is
that a pod is a component of your
application you can run anywhere within
a cluster on Cuba natives it can be
scheduled anywhere it could go down if
it goes down it comes back up again it
will be managed effectively by Cuban 18
so make sure we always have the right
number of pods only given time in this
case we have moles instead of pods but
it's pretty much the same thing so I the
key thing here is that as any of them go
down others are coming up and so it's
like kind of a losing battle to try and
bring these servers down it got servers
pods excuse me sir but yeah we could do
the same with the servers to be honest
we can bring the servers back up as well
so we could do auto scaling we could
have managed instance groups that
manager nodes as well as pods but pods
are very small ephemeral units of your
running application they're designed to
be ephemeral and replaceable so
therefore when one goes away and one
will come back up to replace it
absolutely identical and traffic when we
start to be routed to it again and how
would businesses without kubernetes how
would they handle this without so basic
this is a kind of different way of
thinking a different way of thinking we
been working with with Google for the
last 10 or so years through something
called Borg and basically what people
would do they would find it had lots of
containers they would have to manage
systems and they would have to manage
the container runtimes independently
there are other alternatives accumulated
out there as well the commander's
containers for you but we think
kubernetes is probably the one you
should choose right could we do it and
maybe you could tell us what's happening
on the screen absolutely yeah let's go
so we'll just have drea wax and pods
okay so the trio is currently working
the pods the pods are going down they
have big patch names so you can see each
name is unique when they go down they go
gray when they're coming back up again
they get orange you know become blue
again maybe you do arson up you'll be
able to take the entire service down but
not for very long so you can imagine
somebody's playing havoc with your
systems pods down for you make sure you
always have the right number of pollen
and at any given time that's a pretty
great storage area but when we were
doing it together is there anything else
you want to say about kubernetes or
where people can get started so yeah so
you can go to kubernetes go out to get
started that's the best place to start
from a documentation standpoint there
are lots and lots of resources out there
there are great talks on YouTube meet
including lots of songs from kubernetes
you can find out more there we also have
for anybody who's actually attending the
event an expert station here where you
can go and get questions answered
so there's a lot of stuff around
kubernetes here at the event today but
plenty of resources online and you can
also tweet us on twitter and get your
questions answered as well
awesome thank you so much thanks you
know drea I've been really looking
forward to all the machine learning at
cloud next this year that's a hot topic
is a hot topic so it's about time that
we checked it out we're here with Kaz
Kaz would you mind introducing yourself
and telling everybody out there what you
do I thank you so much I'm Kaz I'm a
developer advocate for Google crowd here
we have a so-called find you can see
demonstrations where you can tell you
some voice commands to the tablet so
that your robot can understand your
voice command and try to find the best
candy for you and pick it up by
recognizing the image so there's a
number of different machine learning
algorithms going on they're both in the
voice recognition and understanding not
just what you said but what it means as
well as selecting the candy can you just
walk us through that flow yeah so
initially it's using the voice speech
API to recognize your voice and then it
uses the natural language API
understand the words inside the sentence
and then it uses the colada machine
learning to use the algorithm is called
water to be what the topic is and our
goal is to understand the meaning of
each words so it understands the
different the similarity between the hot
and spicy or creamy and milky and then
it tries to use the word to choose the
best candies to pick up and finally it
uses the cloud ml again to recognize the
two the image recognition on the each
object it's a lot of machinery all right
shall we try it yeah yeah you can try it
see I like minutes little voice
recognition I see it it's finding the
whole sentence there it knows what each
of those words is a [ __ ] it's gonna
pick out the noun right yes so it
understands all the this part of speech
reckon now jecht him and now it's
chooses the best can this way look it
chooses mints so talked with I know
we're sorting some candy here but talk
to us like how this translate for
enterprises and for businesses so this
is a miniature version of the real-world
use cases and here we we have the all
the displays for the equipment solder
mm-hmm actually we have a real cumin
farmer in Japan who introduced who used
the same technologies to build his own
cumin sorter and she spent only a 15
dollars to build his own equipment so -
by using you could Google cross machine
learning technology that's really cool
yeah so essentially takes the best
prototype of that and kind of buckets
them or yeah yeah so he wanted to build
the machine hook that can sort out the
old or the cucumber's into nine
different classes and she took a 9,000
different photos for his cucumbers and
now and also building sort of by using
the Raspberry Pi and download the tinsel
for the machine learning library from
Google to build his own sorter and the
point here is that either had to be an
cutting edge data scientist or machine
learning expert to getting started with
the latest machine learning technology
attendees are having a great time
exploring that area and getting to know
Google cloud in a whole new way now
Before we jump to a rundown of what to
expect from today's keynotes I want to
make sure that everyone knows they can't
miss the keynote tomorrow
the theme is open source and we have an
extraordinary lineup plant
I'll let Sam and Sarah tell you about it
so day 3 is kind of unique when you look
at it on the schedule what's happening
day 3 that you're excited about it's
gonna be a lot of fun actually Sarah's
very shy as you can tell and didn't
mention that she's the Past co-chair of
Oz con so when we started imagining what
do we want day 3 to look like I thought
well you know we've got two totally
awesome people we've got Sara Pascoe
chair and Kelsey Heights our current
co-chair of Oz Council what if we could
made a three sort of this open-source
technology destination where just be
amazingly fun to share ideas to learn
from people at Google who are building
the open-source technologies and just
open up a big conversation on not just
tensorflow and kubernetes and apache
bheem but all the open-source projects
that we're running on and that we're
contributing to and bringing our experts
to bear so that we can get a really a
live discussion happening and we have
long-standing experts to bear we open
with Vint Cerf talking about how
openness was a fundamental underpinning
of the internet critical one might say
yeah and of course Eric Brewer her low
key develops cap theorem and then lo she
recently broke it it should be a lot of
fun I bet there's gonna be some amazing
stories told tomorrow most definitely as
for today new products for Google cloud
platform and G suite will be announced
and our leading product and engineering
leaders including ORS pravakar Brian and
Chet will share roadmaps of Google
clouds future product direction you also
see exciting product demos and hear from
customers about how Google cloud is
helping them compete and succeed oh I
can't wait so remember we'll be back
here tomorrow about 20 minutes before
the keynote with day two and review and
more exclusive interviews you won't want
to miss we'd love to hear your thoughts
on the future of the cloud or answer any
questions for you while we're here with
all of our experts
our handles are on your screen so enjoy
the show and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you